hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday my podcast and I'm
just checking in on you I'm not yelling
okay
I'm not screaming this thing this
[ __ ] weekend I'm not doing it I ate
too much yesterday and I'm [ __ ] real
action alright and now this is the third
attempt I've made at this [ __ ]
podcast I keep having to hit a race
because you know what I don't have
anything funny to say because I haven't
been [ __ ] doing anything because I've
been studying for this goddamn [ __ ]
test huh you guys want to hear what I've
been looking at you want to hear so how
would you pre-flight check the altimeter
prior to an IFR flight set the altimeter
29.92 with current temperature and
altimeter indication determine the true
altitude to compare with the field
elevation or B set the altimeter to two
Niner point nine or two and then you get
Giggy or C set the altimeter to Kearney
alternative instead of the indication
should be within seventy five for that
I've been doing that oh my god it's a
good thing though it's a good you know
something well you know what happens to
a lot of [ __ ] adults is the last test
we take for most of us is you know right
before we graduate college and you never
have to memorize a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
again for the rest of your life you know
so then you're not getting a report card
so you're really you just you just sort
of you float you don't know where the
[ __ ] you are right you're in the clouds
sorry
everything's gonna go back to that right
you have no idea what kind of a [ __ ]
person you are okay and nobody is is
grading you you're not getting any sort
of a progress [ __ ] report about who
the [ __ ] you are and then you K you're
living in your house okay you married a
woman now she's your property okay
you're telling her what to do all your
kids are afraid of you okay you're in
the bubble right now there's no
difference between
you and Tom Cruise at that point you
know you're not making twenty million
dollars a movie but when you walk
through the front door your [ __ ]
house you're the star of the show that's
it you don't get tested so I don't know
if that's [ __ ] true all I know is the
only time I've taken tests in my adult
life I took the test to get to get my
license to sell health insurance Jesus
Christ there was a left turn in the path
of my life had to take it three [ __ ]
times I'd remember those two parts to
the test there was it was something like
that the [ __ ] the life and there's
something else I don't what the hell it
was all I know it's on the first time I
took it I passed the first part flunked
the second half and then the next time I
flunked the first half passed the second
half and then the third time I finally
passed the [ __ ] thing and I just
because I didn't know I didn't
understand what at that point in my life
I didn't understand passion and
something that you liked and cuz your
whole [ __ ] beginning of your life is
that people gonna read this I know you
on it and if you flunk you're gonna be
right back here again next [ __ ] you
and everything was about you just had to
do all this [ __ ] you didn't want to
[ __ ] do so I think that's how I ended
up doing that just somebody's mind with
selling health insurance and they were
making money is like I'll do that
make money buy stuff be happy right does
that work seems to be working for the
Kardashians right how happy they are
taking pictures of their babies
surrounded by Birkin bags it's one of
the saddest things I've ever seen
don't get me started Birkin bags you
know they were trying to buy one of
those [ __ ] things and then you see
how much they are it's like this is for
a [ __ ] bag and then you show up
they're not even in the goddamn store
you gotta get put on a wish list hey
buddy as the rock said you can take that
bag turn it up this one is made out of
flamingos is it could fit all my [ __ ]
botox in there and my ass and play
yes it's a [ __ ] the dumbest thing
I've ever seen in my life so what am I
talking about so I've been sitting here
I've been underwater with this [ __ ] and
I don't I'm taking the test next month
so what I'm doing now is I'm eight
chapters and I just go through in the
next eight days I'm going through each
chapter four [ __ ] times
alright and then we switch to two a days
alright like football in Texas in July I
go to two-a-days chapter 1 to chapter
three four five six seven eight and then
I'm gonna go to for a days because at
that point I'll know it that well bing
bang bang bang boom and then I'm gonna
sit down on a focal Turkish club didn't
test it I'm gonna [ __ ] pass it that's
that's that's what I've decided
alright and you could tell from the
tenseness in my [ __ ] voice I just I
just want to get through this [ __ ]
that's the thing about aviation it's
[ __ ] fascinating but they taking
these [ __ ] tests blows you know once
you once you get the air and you apply
it then it's ahh this is fun I get this
I don't know I don't what am i bitching
you guys about for huh it's Thanksgiving
I should be thankful you know why cuz we
got rivalry Saturday and I got a bunch
of people coming over tomorrow which
just means I got to do chapter 4 before
I watch Michigan Ohio State so I told
everybody to come over at [ __ ] 10
o'clock we're gonna take the goddamn
game shut your phones off and I'm just
gonna wake up early after I get my
lovely daughter ready to go and all that
stuff make everybody breakfast and all
that [ __ ] I'm doing Chapter four twice
before you know before the game that I'm
watching the game and then I'm doing it
two more times and then I'm going to
Slayer because that's how I live my life
no [ __ ] free time I fill it all up
fill it all up I don't talk about my
feelings and then I lose my [ __ ] and I
hurt people around me but I have more
material right and that's what keeps the
heat on okay and I keep trying to
explain that to the people in my life
that are absolutely terrified of me
flying off the [ __ ] handle and they
just don't get it and I was thinking in
2020 to start adding physical abuse to
the verbal abuse that I do to the people
in my life you know I think it's time
with all this woke Ness you know
just just for the balance you know what
I mean I'm worried that white chicks
aren't gonna have anything to complain
about in 2020 so I figured I'd slap a
few [ __ ] people around you know you
know find somebody in a wheelchair and
like let the air out of the tire I'll do
something give him something to be like
my heart breaks for this oh my god I am
like crying right now it's one of my
favorite things on social media is when
people try to make whatever you're
watching not about what you're watching
anymore they're their reaction to it oh
my I was just like I was sobbing nobody
cares nobody cares what you were doing
this isn't about you well that's not how
it is everything's about [ __ ] you so
anyway I don't have I don't have
anything [ __ ] funny to say I've just
had my goddamn [ __ ] nose in a book
like I'm [ __ ] back of my goddamn
teenage years again but I can't tell you
this when I get past this [ __ ] thing
I'm gonna be a much better pilot which
is important right it is worth something
isn't it does anybody know does anybody
know I don't [ __ ] know all right you
know what what I mean when I'm in a rut
like this okay and I'm staring at
another [ __ ] 23 minutes of a goddamn
podcast and I got no [ __ ] idea what
the hell I can even talk about this is
when I go on the Internet
alright I go on the internet and I type
in the old [ __ ] Google News I know
already know it's gonna be it's gonna be
20 [ __ ] articles about what a
douchebag Trump is you know people just
[ __ ] it's like I get it just don't
vote for the guy all you gonna do is
tell me the fucked-up [ __ ] he's doing
and then you're not gonna offer a
solution and then if people are gonna
write a bunch of hysterical [ __ ]
comics underneath it okay - killed in
London Bridge stabbing police say I bet
they were I bet they were tourists you
know because they thought that
they thought the tower bridge was the
[ __ ] was the London Bridge Jesus two
people killed oh it's a terror attack my
fault my fault sorry I just thought was
a standard mugging jesus [ __ ] christ
I want to warn you some of the video
you're about to show you was graphic
people complaining that it wasn't
graphic oh my god oh this is why would I
do you know I was trying to come here to
find some comedy and I just found the
tragedy they I got the wrong mask
Ukrainian officials discussing ways to
improve standing with Trump what the
[ __ ] are you worried about the guy who
the worst case scenario is only around
for another five years
I want Ukraine been around longer than
this guy in Afghanistan Trump creates
confusion over US policy on Taliban yeah
right falling oil prices maybe miss
reading a 10 Eunice situation tenuous
situation in Iraq oh boy I don't notice
why don't why don't we just leave those
those people alone over there Lee Malone
switch to solar power get some electric
cars they're [ __ ] faster they're
weird-looking but you let them sit there
on the oil let them have it the [ __ ]
we do it electricity that whole argument
electricity I mean it requires oil to
turn the [ __ ] turf I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't get we don't need to go over
there to pretend to help them anymore we
don't have to go bankrupt solar power
[ __ ] Sun shines on every goddamn
country there you go boom done
solving the Middle Eastern problem on a
podcast by himself
watch tesslar cyber truck beat Ford
f-150 Super Duty in a tug of war I gotta
see this they should have led with this
[ __ ] video dude what is that door
stop looking thing all right here we go
I don't understand where do you put
anything in the inlet in the truck it
seems to be enclosed all right here we
go
ap 240 okay we got it and there's the
other thing all right
Tesla cyber truck all right did this
really happen what the [ __ ] am I want
it's not like a legitimate [ __ ] site
that Jesus Christ 29 year old
millionaire who saves 99 percent of his
income shares the two things he refuses
to spend money on
I got it read there I mean Jesus Christ
29 year old millionaire 99 percent of
his income this kid's gonna get mugged
all right it's a foggy to learn anything
for the Kardashians stop going on TV
showing what the [ __ ] you got all right
Graham Stefan can afford to buy nearly
anything he wants the 29 year old earns
up to two hundred twenty five hundred
twenty thousand dollars in a single
month not to not to be a [ __ ] but that's
about a hundred grand after taxes I feel
lucky maybe to keep 90 at this point and
it's on track to make a minimum of 1.6
million in 2019
still oh look who it is it's the lovely
Nia how you doing
how was your Thanksgiving it was
wonderful do you feel like I'm TMZ and I
just caught you at the airport
caught off guard right now what should I
do
do I play the game cuz it's Hollywood
baby what are you talking about as far
as what oh now you're in the airport all
right I don't know what just you know I
have no idea I think we're both hungover
from food oh I don't know which way you
were going with it okay all right let's
start over again what did I ask you all
right hey Nia there's a 29 year old
millionaire he earns two hundred twenty
grand a month and he saves 99% of his
income and there's two things
he won't [ __ ] speed goes I've always
enjoyed the aspect of not spending money
even as a kid I end up saving about
ninety nine percent of my income just
because my income is so high and I keep
my expenses so low Nia you can learn
something here all right I think all
women yes and that you'd go back and
forth of me oh my god are you putting on
a me undies onesie Nia tell us about the
me on z1z and what it's done for you
around the house and post-thanksgiving
you know relaxation you liking it how
much did you spend on that
no I think this kid would approve of it
all right I end up saying about
ninety-nine percent of my income Stephan
whose net worth crossed 1 million for
the first time at 26 good for him
keeps his cost down partly by refusing
to spend money on two things number one
is coffee now Jesus Christ is everything
just [ __ ] here I think the markup of
coffee at Starbucks and a coffee bean
and a lot of those places out there is
absolutely ridiculous so I make it at
home for 20 cents he buys his coffee
it's I almost did it I almost did it
this was a [ __ ] advertisement with
Yale get that they they got me twice
here why do dogs kick their feet after
they poop Jesus what a slow see what
happened if you just keep feed all the
Americans make us all [ __ ] fat
there's no news this weekend but I've
asked the question I don't want to leave
you hanging
let me sift through all the [ __ ] why
it's instinct dogs are ever village
another canines encroaching on their
territory be at the backyard of the park
they consider defecation a message to
other dogs that the pooped on property
belongs to them does anybody know this
dogs obviously can't talk okay they're
eliminating waste by kicking up dirt
after the deed they're compounding the
scent by stirring up the bathroom scene
along with pheromones which come from
glands on their feet to create a strong
smell they kicked up grass is that why
dogs smell [ __ ] the kicked up grass is
also a visual cue all of this poop and
disrupted earth is worn to other dogs
that they are treading on hallowed
stinky ground ah [ __ ] yeah how do they
know that you know I mean if they can't
definitively tell me if having an egg
over easy is good for me or bad for me
they've jumped over that fence 15 times
in my [ __ ] life okay if they can't
even [ __ ] do that
all right we can have a human being that
you can communicate with eat the egg and
be like how do you feel right now right
if they can't [ __ ] figure that out
you they can they can figure out our dog
taking a [ __ ] whether it's is good I
mean is marking its territory [ __ ]
one dead 22 rescued at border after
heavy rains in California I've never
seen a state not be able to deal with
[ __ ] rain the way this one they can't
[ __ ] Drive in it you know nobody has
an umbrella and all of a sudden somebody
like literally would drown in a puddle
you know they got the ass in plants
they'll get used to them they lose their
balance you know they fall down Botox
makes them skinny and that's it then
they just they just go on to a couple
attacked on London bus say thugs asked
how lesbians have sex did anything good
happen out here
China mixing military and science in
Arctic push okay Leonardo DiCaprio
blamed by brazil's president for amazon
forest fires
i thought he was an environmentalist man
this is joe what the [ __ ] is site am i
on this is google news this is what's
going on Jesus Christ all right [ __ ] all
of it alright I apologize I put you know
something this this [ __ ] podcast is a
goddamn disgrace it's late it's not
entertaining okay I you know evidently
you see all you guys have been making
fun of me for all of this [ __ ] time
about how dumb I am how I can't read out
loud and all of this [ __ ] right and here
I what do I do I put my [ __ ] nose in
a book for the last 72 hours and then
look look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] show you
left with
all right let's read the Gandhi I'm
advertising all right I promise you guys
after I passed this test this is the
last book I'll ever be reading actually
get a bunch of books I need to read just
stacked up here people keep and keep
giving me books I got the code
good book called Apache Texas Flood I
still got to read read Odyssey what else
do I get here
Springfield confidential I read The
Beastie Boy boys Beastie Boys heart a
hardcover book Michael Rapaport this
book has balls give me that book like
[ __ ] three years ago I still haven't
read it I always feel like when somebody
gives me a book it's like a [ __ ]
practical joke you know I mean it'd be
like if somebody was like [ __ ]
tone-deaf or something like that you
gave him a goddamn I don't know how to
sing DVD some [ __ ] I don't know
jeez bill Jay Jesus stop [ __ ] stop
reading all right quip everybody quip
the holiday shopping season is here all
right evidently it's here it is
officially here Black Friday oh my god I
have to kind of look this up real quick
Black Friday did anybody get trampled
Black Friday injuries 2019 comes right
up okay The Hague stabbing several
injured at shopping center on Black
Friday today death and injury by Black
Friday sale for stats that will make you
hate Black Friday all right hang on a
second all right hang on what do we got
here death and injury every Thanksgiving
holiday season it's just like just get
to the [ __ ] point okay puh-puh-puh
buh-buh-buh nothing happened
Black Friday related injuries and deaths
there this is just I'm just [ __ ]
clickbait guy today The Hague stabbing
maybe this is two hours ago three
injured and stabbing it's shopping
center in The Hague what is the hague
well the netherlands on friday well
that's not Black Friday for them they
don't have [ __ ] Christmas over there
right
the incident happened inside the Hudson
Bay department store along a busy Shabet
look at people
stabbed over [ __ ] wooden shoes that
have [ __ ] 80% off I love this story
Jesus Christ those [ __ ] people over
there they were all like six foot four
and weighed like a hundred and fifty
pounds that could be fatal
their entire body shaped like a [ __ ]
artery all right the three victims were
released from the hospital after being
treated for their injuries police said
the suspect is believed to be a man of
45 to 50 years old police said he was
wearing a grey jogging tracksuit do the
complexity and care this takes time we
understand I said what the [ __ ] happened
the shopping area was busy due to Black
Friday holiday shoppers why would they
have Black Friday on [ __ ] I don't get
it
that would mean they have Thanksgiving
Black Friday wait a second
this is blowing my mind if you got Black
Friday but you don't get Thanksgiving I
gotta tell you another Lynch you're
getting [ __ ] over here is Black Friday
national no international sorry
International International on one point
I'll spell this correctly stores around
the world are adopting Black Friday oh
brother holding their own sales during
Americans Thanksgiving weekend to
compete with American retailers it's no
longer just about snagging the year's
hottest items at bargain prices Black
Friday is a cultural spectate spectacle
that spread overseas ooh oh Jesus Christ
this this is that something else we can
take [ __ ] credit for Black Friday
nuclear weapons overeating you know you
know what [ __ ] you man we can still got
great music we make great movies okay we
got the blue jeans we started that right
muscle cars baseball all right the
pickings getting a little slim here I'm
just gonna save my
Jaxson but that didn't end well I go
[ __ ] yourselves I'm doing this off the
top of my head I'm sure the Grand Canyon
that's a nice one all right
we can't export that can we you can send
pictures sell them on Black Friday quip
the holiday shopping season is here and
this your gift can stat next year's good
habit with quip quip is something that's
sure to put a smile on everyone's mouth
because it's dental care they'll
actually want to use every day all right
that's why equip is the perfect
thoughtful and practical gift with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
toothpaste all international design went
all intentionally designed sorry so make
good habits simple the quip electric
toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations and a timer with 30 second
pulses to guide your your routine and
the quip floss dispenser has pre marked
strings so you always use the right
amount you don't have to use your
[ __ ] brain to do this this is a
minute get it all marked out here you
get all the answers to the test I don't
like the [ __ ] I'm doing right now plus
quip delivered delivers brush heads
floss and toothpaste refills every three
months join over 3 million happy
customers and check every one off your
gift lifts right now with quip I'll get
the [ __ ] is a stocking stuffer come on
quip I'm gonna do that did you get me uh
did you give me a Chanel bag
I did even better I'm gonna save your
dentition with an electric toothbrush
from quip no more wondering have I been
on this tooth long enough you got quip
am i using too much floss am I using too
little now anymore thank you honey I
thought he wanted to design her bag but
what I really wanted was whiter teeth
all right just get the just go to get
quick calm slash bur to save on gift
sets and to get your free refill your
first refill free with a refill plan
does a lot of refills in that sentence
to save on gifts
sets and to get your first refill free
with a refill plan
that's your first refill free at get
quipped qu IP comm / / get quip comm / /
butcher box oh my god I might gag while
I read this I've ate so much [ __ ]
butcher box the last couple of days
not everyone has a butcher box everybody
I got to give a cleaner intro to this
thing butcher box ladies and gentlemen
not everyone has convenient access to
high-quality meat let's leave the
homeless out of this huh luckily there's
butcher box butcher box believes
everyone desired deserves high-quality
humanely sourced meet every month
butcher bucks ships a curated section of
high quality meat right to my home all
meat is free of antibiotics and added
hormones each box has nine to eleven
pounds of meat that's enough for 24
individual meals and it's big enough to
throw through the window at a Walmart so
you can be the first guy in on Black
Friday packed with fresh pack fresh and
shipped frozen and vacuum sealed so it
stays that way you can customize your
box or go with one of theirs either way
you'll get exactly what you want it's
the best meat ship right to your door
which means one less trip to the
groceries my favorite is the heritage
bread pork the best pork chop I have my
goddamn hand at home and my house all
right I thought you can't one of those
fancy chefs there with the names you
can't pronounce they come out their
little clogs okay they give it a little
[ __ ] butter bath okay that's a whole
nother level options like 100% grass-fed
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken heritage pork it's not heritage
breed anymore huh heritage pork
wild-caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what the [ __ ] those fish are gonna
do okay they wild it out talking [ __ ] to
each other and they're being judged and
then you eat them and sugar / nitrate
free bacon butcher box is the most
affordable and convenient way to get
healthy humanely raised me with butcher
bucks you get the highest quality meat
around for just six dollars a meal this
Black Friday your first box comes with
butcher bucks unlimited steak sampler
that's right eight free meals it's [ __ ]
that's eight free steaks just go to
butcher bucks calm slash / or use the
promo code burr at checkout you'll get
two filet mignon
four top sirloins and to New York strips
steaks plus $20 off your first your
first box
this is butcher bucks best deal of the
year and it won't last long so don't
wait go to butcher box com / / to use or
use promo code bird at checkout that's
butcher box calm / burrow or use promo
code burr at checkout Jesus Christ well
I got to tell you right now I think this
is Michigan University the University of
Michigan this is their best chance to
beat Ohio State in a long [ __ ] time
okay they've had a rough go of it to
century but they they what are they they
beat they beat Notre Dame they beat
Michigan State Ohio State really hasn't
played anybody this year played Penn
State other than that every [ __ ] week
Indiana they got a big one against
Rutgers we'll see what happens
oh my god I think it's high time that
state school in Michigan beat that state
school in Ohio I just want to see I want
to see hardball win one you know I don't
know this could be amazing though but I
mean if Michigan wins this one Michigan
was this one they will actually knock
Ohio State out of the playoff which how
hilarious would that be considering all
Ohio State fans do every [ __ ] year is
[ __ ] that they're not in it but that
one [ __ ] year okay when they had one
loss and Penn State also had one loss
and Penn State beat Ohio State and won
the Big Ten championship some tile
[ __ ] Ohio State went to the playoff
and Penn State didn't you didn't hear
anybody in Columbus complained about
that no you did not
it's a [ __ ] one-way street right
there in the center / aisle I don't give
a [ __ ] people [ __ ] around just want
to see a good game okay I'm sick of Ohio
State winning I want to see Michigan win
they go there I said it
all right I respect blow programs go
[ __ ] yourselves okay well that is the
podcast this is the heartburn podcast
right after the day after Thanksgiving
today was Black Friday and I got to tell
you something I didn't buy anything I
didn't buy a goddamn thing in fact I
never left the house I went out I
brought the trash barrels in that's what
I did
and I studied for this [ __ ] test hey
guess what I got a long intro here
please intro Justin long podcast clip
you know what Justin Long
the brilliant lovable adorable clean-cut
absolutely you want America you go see
him one of my favorite people in this
business on and off stage ok I did his
podcast alright it's so I'm supposed to
intro intro the podcast clip
alright listen to my full interview with
Justin Long on his weight you know what
here right here is the clip from me on
Justin Long's podcast I always ask who
everyone's favorite Muppet is but I I
hesitate ask it so hard
I can tell you my one of my favorite
sketch is the one with all the monsters
some of us are here such a funny yeah
all the hairy ones yeah yeah but at that
yeah at that dot yeah it was the one
with the horns going up in the baseline
band but they did too with that guy
uh-huh and there's just one of the
things like this guy should have been a
bigger star Muppet uh-huh
so I liked all of that I loved Grover
Grover had such a good heart
Ernie cuz Ernie was silly ya know it's
funny when the funny I liked all the
happy ones that I'm really more offshore
the Grouch but I liked I liked all of it
yeah little kid I used to like when it
was Grover sang a song with this little
like boy Muppet it was G Grover G like
letter G George I used to watch that as
a little kid it would almost make me cry
yeah yeah yeah that was a huge thing and
I it was got my my daughter wasn't into
it at first and now I got her in tah and
that's gotta be one of the best parts
about being it what changed a lot and I
have to met Elmo is sort of the what's
that Star Wars character that everybody
hey char-char Elmo annoys me a little
I always like you know there's always
out there yeah yeah a little too
positive it's a difficult voice to
listen to
yeah it's always [ __ ] when you're
drinking relax
what have a seat alright are you you
liked that didn't you would you like to
listen to the rest of it listen to my
full interview with Justin Long on his
podcast life is short
okay here's a short clip before the
throwbacks oh that's what I was supposed
to say I don't [ __ ] I don't know what
I'm supposed I don't know how it works
alright I would think that I would say
oh you would I'd say hey here's a clip
from me on Justin Long's podcast and
then they play the clip and then I say
hey you want to listen to the full my
full interview with Justin Long on his
podcast life is short I will have a
[ __ ] link for you to click on I said
I would do it anyways listen to this
music now there's music music yes music
and we'll listen to a throwback Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts where I didn't need
half a [ __ ] turkey mashed potatoes
and [ __ ] you know I was thankful for
I actually smoked just cigar with Josh
Adam Maya's at my house after we had
done some stand-up and was sitting out
on the porch and my lovely wife came out
and she heated up some mac and cheese
for us so we had orange Fanta sodas
smoking cigars eating mac and cheese
sitting out there in the cold one of the
great Wednesday night memories I'll ever
have before Thanksgiving alright and I'm
thankful for my lovely wife although I
never tell her that I don't I just I'm a
big believer and not telling the person
you're with what you feel about them
okay and you only bring up stuff when
they do it wrong okay and that is the
secrets of the success of my
relationship all right have a great
weekend go blue go B's go Celtics go
Patriots go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend I'll talk to you
Monday
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
November 28th 2011 how the hell are you
let's get right into this [ __ ] this week
there's been some confusion by about
nine listeners who for some reason can't
find my podcast since I got a new
website if you go on to iTunes you'll
see the old feed and now there's also a
new feed and in the new feed we have all
the [ __ ] you know I just realized I'm
explaining this to people who can't find
the web not the website who can't find
the [ __ ] podcast so then what I'm
really just telling it to people who are
already here and get it because if
you're listening to this you found it so
I feel like that [ __ ] preacher whose
trash and everybody in church who showed
up and where is everybody this week I
don't know but I'm here you [ __ ] go
ahead get on with it
get on with it what what what else did
he do and then he walked on water while
juggling three bushes they were all on
fire he will a roaming at a beard and at
a bunch of Fred's but when this [ __ ] hit
the fan they all turn their backs poor
[ __ ] hippie why did they do that now
they took them down to Home Depot am I
really gonna continue with this and they
got some [ __ ] lumber all right listen
[Laughter]
it's absolutely sacrilegious I actually
you know something I was watching some
some YouTube videos some videos on the
YouTube there
I just think that's a horrible page it's
bad for children they should be out
reading they should be interacting with
one another they shut up lady lady I was
watching some videos on you know people
said they believe in God and people who
are atheists like the YouTube video this
week is a clip of Steve Harvey saying if
you don't believe in God I think you're
an idiot no offense it's just how I feel
and then they show all this [ __ ] about
you know science as far as their version
of what's going on and you know what I
realized watching that nobody knows [ __ ]
nobody nobody can prove anything
nobody can [ __ ] prove any science can
go back to a certain point and then the
the [ __ ] religious people will be like
well then who created the gas man and
then they'll figure that out and they
didn't just keep going back and back and
back and I don't think you're ever gonna
get the answer how the [ __ ] we're all
here so I respect what scientists are
doing because they're like well why
don't we get some definitive answers
instead of just having some fat guy
who's making eyes at my son over here
standing up there going he took a break
cuz he was tired cuz he made all this
stuff and that's what happened go [ __ ]
yourselves
give me some [ __ ] money or else
you'll go to a bad place you know you
got a respect I'm not [ __ ] on all
religious that's just how my religion
went that was actually for black people
out there that's actually considered
singing in church that's what we do we
don't [ __ ] you know sound like
outtakes from some Aretha session we
sound like [ __ ] idiots
that's that's the way they sing in white
church yo that's how we do in the
Catholic hizzy you know anything I was
gonna be funny this week I gotta admit
for the first two minutes I've been
pretty god damn funny four minutes
four minutes a [ __ ] hilarity where
are you right now at work huh
why don't you doing it [ __ ] aren't
you doing your job does it even matter
anymore Hershey you guys like chocolate
huh your tubs of [ __ ] everybody likes
chocolate I like chocolate evidently
they're moving all their [ __ ] you
know plants down to [ __ ] Mexico could
you be any more American than a big
[ __ ] Hershey bar how much more
American does that get then they came
out with the big block for the fatties
you know cuz they don't have time to
have a big gulp
maybe that their their cheeks are sore
if I'm going for [ __ ] you know 97
ounces
okay go hey you know what why don't you
just eat this big block of when we just
give you a goddamn school brick worth of
[ __ ] chocolate that's America right
there and where they going they're going
down to New Mexico which technically is
still the Americas it's North America
yeah who commits south of us because
there's a whole other [ __ ] continent
below that and God made that it was on
the third day and then he made Asia oh I
got to give some shoutouts shoutouts
this week oh snap oh snap annoyed I got
some [ __ ] shout out shout out to
Ashton Kutcher Kutcher why is my voice
cracking I didn't do any shows this
weekend I was [ __ ] lazy actually
played a pick-up hockey game last night
where I didn't know really anybody and
it's always funny when you're the guy
who sucks the most funny is that moment
when they figure it out you know could
you get out on the ice and you're open
and you like me you can skate good
enough where it looks like when they
pass the puck to you that you're going
to be able to stop it as opposed to have
it going things
right off your [ __ ] stick and over to
the defenseman it takes it takes a shift
and a half provided you don't fall down
and do something absolutely horrific on
your first shift but as long as you're
able to stand up you go backwards a
little bit they have faith in you for a
shift and a half and then all of a
sudden you notice you're wide open
you're calling for the puck you're
banging you stick on the ice just like
they do on the [ __ ] TV
and for some reason they'd rather
[ __ ] pass it to somebody else and you
reel off they figured it out I suck you
go back to the bench nobody's looking at
you and you just sitting there man
without a country just looking down the
bench that was your Thanksgiving anybody
okay yeah there's one [ __ ] dude won't
even look at me it's like dude put the
faith what do you say there's sunshine
right over here no see you [ __ ]
carving up the ice either granted you're
not falling down creating a two or none
um no I actually sat there and I was
just like I felt like a douche and I
literally just wanted to go home I was
that much worse than everybody else
there and then I was just like what am I
[ __ ] eight years old I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm going even harder this next
shift and I was a punk Jason jackass cuz
that's what you do when you suck if you
suck you just got to go as hard as you
can so at least they see you got a
little hot you got some [ __ ] hot
by the way the shoutouts let's let's do
the shoutouts oh I was gonna do Ashton
Kutcher let me get back to that it's all
the Buffalo Sabres fans I actually felt
bad for you I did because you wanted
justice okay you want to talk about some
people that probably don't believe in
God right now or at least a hockey God
it has to be fans of the Buffalo Sabres
after Milan Lucic slammed into their
goalie oh I got to show you that YouTube
video when Ryan Miller calls him a piece
of [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] hilarious he
goes you know people say he's a tough
guy and everything and I respected him
but after that player you know it's just
a piece of [ __ ] I mean it's a piece of
[ __ ] move you gotta gotta got a zz he's
piece of [ __ ] and then he walked away
I'm like that's how every Sports
interview should be conducted just say
exactly what you're thinking for those
who are non hockey fans um basically
this is what happened they passed the
puck up to Lucic he had a breakaway but
a bounced off his stick much in the way
every pass on my stick gets bounced
right off so then it's like going down
towards the goalie it's like 20 feet out
in front of him Looch is skating towards
the puck and then Ryan Miller comes out
skating like a goalie waddling like some
fat chick with his big pads alright and
at the last second right as Lucic is
gonna get it he pokes it away and I
think Milan got a little frustrated so
he said I you [ __ ] little [ __ ] and he
slammed into him and then the buffalo
sabres if you hit somebody's goalie
that's it they're supposed to start
frothing at the mouth and just swinging
their sticks and you know what
you know what the Sabres did they did so
they had this big tea meeting and
everybody's like what the how the [ __ ]
did nobody do anything there that was
ridiculous
so the Bruins were playing him again
this past Wednesday and everybody Oh
Milan Lucic is gonna [ __ ] get his
head caved in blah blah blah
so Cheech goes out on the ice third
shift of the game they send out their
fighter their goon their enforcer right
next to him Lou Cheech smiles so here it
is the Sabres gonna beat him down they
drop the gloves
they both take their helmets off they go
at it and loot sheets just pounds this
guy into the [ __ ] ice and I got to
admit I felt the air go out of the
building write that in there um he did
make a nice move later on in the parry
when he got loot Chara to get into a
fight and all Bruins fans got to see how
[ __ ] important that guy is out on the
ice alright that was really [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] left term alright let's
get let's get this a little more
mainstream big shout out to Ashton
Kutcher alright he had to me to me more
have broken up and I'm here to say hats
off to you mr. Kutcher hats off to you
you did the right thing okay
you went out there there was some chick
from your childhood you hooked up with
there you got a little an an
little enamored with her and then what
we got married all that [ __ ] now
you're out of it good for you good for
you let's just unhook there cuz at the
end of the day you have to get out of
that you got to get out of that one
you know these [ __ ] people will get
married to people who were like two
decades older than them you're basically
saying I want to be single at 50 you
know because she looks [ __ ] she looks
better now than she looked back in the
80s but you know at the end of the day
there's no there's no Botox free for you
[ __ ] hat right oh you [ __ ] and if
you look on if you look on the back of
the tube of Botox it comes in a tube
form now it's a cream eye I saw it last
night when I was watching
Cyndi's theorem if you look in the
warning label it says warning does not
help your heart or your [ __ ] it says it
right in the back of the tube of Botox
just to let you know good for him that's
that that that is a good move all right
cuz I know she looks like she's 26
but her womb is so polluted no at this
point I mean can she even have a kid at
this point like what what is what is the
point in continuing that one you got to
get out of there right I think he made a
great move I don't know about you guys
so that's my shout out of the week
that's a tough [ __ ] move you got to
leave an icon you got to leave a [ __ ]
icon and just say listen alright I know
I know you're 53 I've been on your
Wikipedia page I know how [ __ ] old you
are this is ridiculous I'm still 31 I'm
in the prime of my [ __ ] life and I
know you look good on the red carpet but
let me tell you something when I see you
walk down the hall in the morning and
your face is all shiny and all that type
of [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] maid why am I
doing this
why would I do this why does that keep
unhooking
because they keep moving it um anyway so
let's get on with the podcast here how
was you guys Thanksgiving did I bring it
up last week up I I really feel like I
let you guys down that the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving is one of the the
greatest holidays it's one of the
greatest [ __ ] holidays of the year
here in the United States and I don't
it's never really talked about it's
[ __ ] underground all right that's the
one where if you're a young fella okay
or a young lady right yo-yo your
semester you know you're halfway through
a semester you come home and you go down
to the local watering hole and win in
its it's it's just shooting fish in a
barrel
all those broads you wanted to bang four
[ __ ] high school but you were
something you too much of a [ __ ] nerd
you know yeah I know what happened you
[ __ ] up in second grade and he ended
up in the wrong croup you had some
[ __ ] snot hanging from your nose and
then they called you [ __ ] snot-nosed
and then there's killed any chance of
getting any [ __ ] [ __ ] in your town
well now you're coming back like the
[ __ ] road warrior you can go down
there you can nobody knows what you're
doing now you don't go to school you can
just be this whole different person I
can't believe I let you guys down and
didn't bring it up that's the day that's
the day to go down that [ __ ] broad
you always wanted a bank that's the
night the Wednesday before Thanksgiving
you go down to the [ __ ] townie
watering hole in your local town get
yourself a scarf throw it around your
neck look mysterious have a little bit
of stubble going on right you just go
down there and you you know try to try
to try to go back and make up for lost
time
it's the closest thing to a time machine
you're ever gonna get to you know it's
or or I would say like the the movie The
Nutty Professor back in high school you
were the [ __ ] nerd you know in the
original one or you were the tub of [ __ ]
and now you come back you're Billy Ray
Valentine and I let you guys down
there's a couple of things I let you
guys down with
you know what's funny my girl came to me
the lovely Nia and you know we just
moved into a new place I don't have a
[ __ ] dining room table so we decided
that we're gonna go out to a restaurant
sacrilegious by the way sacrilegious on
Turkey Day and when we ended up going to
the stinking rose which is just this
[ __ ] garlic crazed I don't know what
it was but they actually had a turkey
Thanksgiving dinner that was [ __ ]
delicious but but I I want to get into
it at the end they had dessert I got the
pumpkin pie and Nia got this garlic ice
cream with hot fudge on the top of it
just go and just try it it's interesting
try it I got I don't want to try I know
yeah just keep going higher up with that
boys okay fine I'll [ __ ] do it stop
asking me so I tried it was [ __ ]
horrific as horrific as you would think
I love garlic but I never think oh let
me stick in an ice cream with some hot
fudge on it was horrific so anyways
before we go over there before we go
over there she goes um I have something
to tell you I think I might have screwed
up and I'm like what do you mean you
might have screwed up she's like well
so-and-so doesn't have any place to go
for Thanksgiving and they asked if they
could come and I said okay I felt bad
it's okay if so it so comes and I go no
I go no she goes what do you mean no I
go no she goes but he doesn't have any
place to go
that's cuz he's a douche all right I
mean that's why I can't believe I didn't
bring this up last week I should have
[ __ ] warned you guys cuz I know some
of you guys have lived this you know
that [ __ ] guy who has nowhere to go
and then somebody feels bad for him
because it's the feel bad for people
time of year
so you gotta [ __ ] invite this person
over give me a [ __ ] break okay unless
you just went through a divorce you just
moved across
the country or your I don't know what
you fell out of a [ __ ] satellite
there's no reason that you don't have
anywhere to go on Thanksgiving all right
I guess there are reasons but 9 out of
10 times the reason is you're a douche
okay if you're in your 30s and 40s you
have it you've had three to four decades
to make friends to eat with oh my god
give me a [ __ ] break
thank God the person didn't show up cuz
I tell you right now if we were havin
Thanksgiving over here I just would have
said no I met the guy one time I after
five minutes I was like I want to [ __ ]
kill this guy you know five minutes I
didn't know the guy five minutes early
earlier five minutes later I think I
want to [ __ ] kill this guy you know I
might even want to kill myself murder
suicide just so I can forget how awful
this [ __ ] conversation is no wonder
this guy doesn't have anywhere to go for
Thanksgiving he came up to me and the
Celtics were playing the Lakers
I said I'm for Boston I got yeah I hate
the Lakers right you know he goes what
do you mean you hate the Lakers oh yeah
I hate the Lakers he spends five minutes
trying to convince me that I don't hate
the Lakers it's such a ridiculous
argument I finally just go alright
you're right I don't hate the Lakers and
he goes what are you can't just tap out
you can't just abandon your argument and
I just went like dude you are a [ __ ]
crazy person and I walked away from him
and then the whole rest of time over
there I keep every time I would look
across the room he sort of be just like
staring at me and I'm looking back at
him like what you're a you're a douche
the [ __ ] away from me so this is the guy
I just feel bad he's got nowhere to go
you know like he doesn't have any sort
of responsibility in the fact that he
has nowhere to go
you're an argumentative [ __ ] [ __ ] sit
next to that guy on Thanksgiving I'm
trying to throw down as he tries to
convince me that I don't like Turkey one
of those douchebags who probably order
something vegetarian on that day and
make some big production
about it I just feel bad I just feel bad
um anyways you know what I got a huge
week this week I just got exhausted
yelling about somebody I don't even give
a [ __ ] about um you know something I
really got to get some chairs down here
because this whole laying on the floor
with my [ __ ] melon against the wall
is really starting to get old anyways so
this is my week this week everybody I'm
doing a gig in western Massachusetts
alright at the Western Massachusetts
Pauley Pavilion I don't even know the
name of the [ __ ] thing hang on a
second oh let me go to my new website by
the way if you guys we got uh was a slow
week this week for um
emails and that type of [ __ ] which I
understand why it's the holiday season
dooby-dooby-doo inviting people who got
nowhere to go oh that's right they're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh there it is the [ __ ]
it'd cut all right I'm at the Calvin
theater December 1st North Hampton
Massachusetts December 2nd I'm at the
Borgata music box Atlantic City New
Jersey and on the 3rd I'm at the Byam
theater in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania that
is my weekend if you go to Bill Bird
calm and you click on events it'll give
you links to all the tickets I got a
brand new Irish [ __ ] you [ __ ]
come on down and see it and also we had
a slow week for our emails just to
remind everybody the emails for the
podcast for advice and all that because
everybody was sending them to my other
email address send it to Bill at the mm
podcast comm bill at the mm podcast comm
and I'll read your [ __ ] and hopefully
it'll lead to some sort of hi Larry
so you probably say to yourself what
Jesus bill you're going in Massachusetts
you go to New Jersey and you go into
Pittsburgh is that all you're doing you
gonna come right home after that [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no on November 30th the Bruins play
the [ __ ] Maple Leafs up and Maple
Leaf Gardens
I don't know what they call there do one
I'm going to that game then I'm going
over to Massachusetts to do my gig then
I go down to Jersey to do that gig then
I go over to Pittsburgh
and a [ __ ] hang and they I haven't
even told Nia this she's gonna get so
[ __ ] mad at me and I'm hanging there
the next day I'm going to Pittsburgh the
Bengals and then on Monday I going up to
Ottawa doing a little hockey trip here
with the football game in the middle of
it why not the [ __ ] else do I got to do
huh am I gonna go holiday shopping with
all these [ __ ] maniacs and get pepper
sprayed cuz I'm trying to buy a juicer
you know I haven't I don't have one
ounce of [ __ ] sympathy for any
[ __ ] idiot out there I don't give a
[ __ ] about your financial goddamn
position go make a popsicle stick house
okay
don't [ __ ] go down to Walmart and sit
there with your goddamn [ __ ] big gulp
face pressed against the glass trying to
run down a [ __ ] an aisle with for
another crazed maniacs trying to get a
waffle iron the [ __ ] is wrong with you
walk in there like a gentleman
alright go in there some other time when
it's not [ __ ] mayhem why don't you do
this pay full price and buy less [ __ ]
why don't you do that you know and well
let me guess is this insensitive well
then you just buy less [ __ ] how it you
know you don't the fastest [ __ ] way
to still having no money is to go down
to a [ __ ] department store and buy a
ton of [ __ ] these people that they're
there they're [ __ ] idiots you know
I'm not saying that they weren't blessed
that they didn't get some gifts from a
high up I'm not saying that I'm not
saying that some of them can't sing a
song can't do a dance can't fix a
[ __ ] motor I'm not saying that this
is why I'm saying you're a [ __ ] idiot
because you're buying into the hype the
same way those stupid [ __ ] nerd [ __ ]
buy into this [ __ ]
I whatever iPad iPod the new iPhone
every [ __ ] goddamn six months they
get themselves all worked up into this
[ __ ] frenzy and they're going on the
website trying to show how many there
how many there it's it's completely it's
false panic it's man-made I swear to God
you know what kills me as Walmart has I
have not been able to find their
reaction um to basically I mean aren't
they in a sales way screaming fire in a
crowded movie theater isn't this what I
mean every [ __ ] year I remember this
security guard got trampled he had a
[ __ ] heart attack the guy died
because somebody's trying to go down and
buy a [ __ ] he-man doll for a Half
Price you know so somebody can pop the
head off and have a toddler get it
lodged in their throat these are all
facts people all this shit's happened
all right Porter Ranch where the [ __ ] is
Porter Ranch that just sounds like the
one of those still in those states right
just a good ol boy Mayer meaning no harm
went down to the Walmart do you get some
[ __ ] chaps and he shot of unarmed man
gotten his Challenger and then he
[ __ ] drove away what the [ __ ] is that
I lost it woman pepper-sprayed Porter
Ranch all right Porter Ranch um would
you like balsamic vinaigrette or would
you like the Porter Ranch here we go
you can't Porter Ranch now let's [ __ ]
Los Angeles get the [ __ ] out of here is
in affluent neighborhood in the
Northwest region of the San Fernando
Valley see look at me getting exposed
for The [ __ ] I am that's even worse
you know I refuse to believe that rich
people went down to a [ __ ] Walmart
with pepper spray I'm not buying this
one have they seen the lady who did it
anyways people stop buying into this
[ __ ] crap you know take some power
back in your own life you know what you
should do on Black Friday stay home
st. Patrick's Day bunch of people morons
going out drinking their faces off being
loud the green alligator is singing
these stupid songs with plastic hats on
their heads and eventually they're
really gonna punch you in the face or
throw up on your shoes stay home like a
[ __ ] gentleman go out go down to the
liquor store get yourself a nice bottle
of scotch have a few friends come over
you know make you corned beef sandwiches
there you know and then watch some
[ __ ] Irish mob movie go watch the
state of grace or some [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] know but you don't go down there
for that horseshit you don't go out on
Valentine's go on to Valentines go get
yourself sushi that's been marked up
300% go [ __ ] yourself you go out on the
15th I can't say I love you on that day
you know independent thought people on a
very low level
I'm not reinventing the wheel I'm just
realizing there's other days in the year
where you can go and walk into a store
and buy a [ __ ] Flowbee without
getting they'll get a run through with
the [ __ ] swifter mop handle ah it's
just should have said swifter there's a
lesson in comedy without getting run
through by a [ __ ] swifter that would
have been funny but I was got run
through whether Swift a mop handle it's
like I was in a band and I stopped
[ __ ] late yeah Jesus oh geez bill you
can't even say it funny let's read about
this Porter Ranch what the [ __ ] is it
what did I just do for chrissake hey
what's going on with Wikipedia where
every time you go on it now they're like
asking for money like they're PBS oh my
god we provide such a service we don't
charge for it I'm actually gonna give
him some money
because all of my uninformed knowledge
comes from them um what am I looking up
here let's just write pepper spray
pepper spray Black Friday why don't we
do that and then we click on
my fox el a.com giving them a shout out
uh they know I really have to stop
saying shout out all right Porter Ranch
the woman accused of shooting pepper
sprayed other customers at a busy
Walmart store in Porter Ranch injuring
20 was described by police today is
about five foot three inches tall
between the ages of 32 and 38 with black
hair and brown eyes police do not have a
description of the vehicle the woman was
driving well I'd like to make a guess if
I could uh I'm gonna say she was driving
some sort of Chrysler vehicle probably
some rusted out cab forward designed you
know with one of the taillights you know
the backup lights hanging down Los
Angeles Police Department
[ __ ] detective said detectives are
actively working on the case but are not
expected to receive surveillance video
from Walmart until early next week
because of technical glitches how
hilarious is that I bet if that [ __ ]
went in there and robbed the [ __ ]
store cleaned out all the registers how
quickly think Walmart where they got
that video over yeah you know week you
don't have technical glitches that's how
[ __ ] powerful Walmart is they just
told the cops to stand down we'll get
you the video when our lawyers are done
looking at it that's what the [ __ ] that
means
do you how much money we generate for
this community officer huh
I live in a gated community
with my own [ __ ] private police force
that has better guns than yours we'll
get you the video when we're good and
goddamn [ __ ] ready no wonder Walmart
hasn't made a comment you know they
never used to have this [ __ ] when I was
a kid or at the very least it was never
reported you know they'd start to have
sales but it wasn't this [ __ ] mania
I'm an [ __ ] I got to do that next
year next year I'm gonna hire a camera
crew and I'm gonna go down there and I
want to just [ __ ] start talking to
these people and asking what is all the
excitement
about what do you think is in there
that's gonna make your life better huh
what he thinks in there and don't give
me this sad-sack [ __ ] story about how
you got kids and it's Christmastime and
if there's no presence under the [ __ ]
tree what's gonna happen gee I don't
know
biggie smalls seemed to make it work
didn't he he just rapped about being
broke and everyone related to it and
then he made a sold a bunch of albums
and then he got shot alright that was a
bad example look all I'm saying is this
alright there's no reason you know
you're probably thinking that I'm
trashing you for going I just don't want
you I want you to just have [ __ ]
respect for yourself like those [ __ ]
idiots when they go to a goddamn game
and those skipping jackasses come out
with the free t-shirts and everybody the
reaching over everybody I just wish once
I could just have some sort of crowd
mind control and as they sat there you
know skipping around with their eyebrows
up like hat
everybody just sort of sits there
staring back at them until it's so
[ __ ] awkward they just have to throw
it and then it just sort of lands in the
aisle and nobody picks it up then of
course the people in the arena is like
well someone's gonna trip on that we're
gonna get sued and then they gotta send
those skipping jackasses to go pick up
all their t-shirts that nobody want and
then they're left with a [ __ ]
truckload of them that's what I would
like to see happen stop trying to get me
excited about [ __ ] you know what Walmart
hasn't it it has a bunch of [ __ ] what
are they really having it bicycles
Foreman grills jackets rakes what else
do they got [ __ ] DVD player I mean
you can't get one of those for $9 on the
goddamn internet I don't know I just
think if you're in a financial position
well you have to risk being trampled to
death will you basically have to go to
the store version of the Running of the
Bulls to get a goddamn [ __ ] I don't
know grilled cheese maker I'm running
out of dumb [ __ ] to talk about or a
Playstation or whatever the [ __ ] it is
if you have to do that you can't afford
it and if you go out and buy the [ __ ]
thing you're just sticking yourself
further behind the [ __ ] rock why
don't you just have a couple of light
Christmases so then he can have a better
Christmas you know why don't you do that
instead of doing what all these [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] in that real housewife wife
show do you know pay for that cash money
those [ __ ] morons who do not
understand money you know yeah just live
with nothing for a while as long as you
can [ __ ] eat and you got plenty of
water you're fine
do you realize if you have enough to eat
and you have water do you realize that
you're you're living better then
probably a third of the world just doing
that having a place to take a [ __ ]
having clothes on your back having
toothpaste and toothbrush do you
understand how [ __ ] far ahead you are
you don't need any of that [ __ ] and yes
it's nice to have but it's not worth
going down there and falling down and
having your wig fall off or your [ __ ]
ass crack hangin out all this [ __ ] that
I've seen dislocating your knee having
some poor bastard trying to hold people
back in hands a heart attack need eyes
oh you sob too small I need a
competitive edge let me go get some bear
mace like do you understand like how
caught up into the [ __ ] frenzy you
are that you make those goddamn
decisions you don't even need to be down
there just go down to a [ __ ] Osco
drug do those things still exist
whatever happened in the old days
Lechmere sir
remember that was talking
but that was somebody's yesterday go
down to Lechmere when you got out of the
lumberyard go make some toys like a
[ __ ] elf anything anything you know
other than I mean couldn't you just go
like look we don't have to say to your
kids we don't have money for Christmas
this year all right we don't but I do
have money to take you to a ball game
I'll take us all out to a ball game all
right and just know this we're gonna
have better Christmases but the most
important thing is that we're all
together we all love each other and that
we don't get trampled by some hot
dog-eating jackass with a can of [ __ ]
bear mace it's more important to me
[ __ ] showing up Christmas you know
dressed up as Santa Claus with your
dislocated shoulder and your [ __ ]
eyes are all red
oh don't hug Santa that hurts I'm sure
I'm gonna get some [ __ ] hate mail
over this that was so insensitive to
people who don't have money I know they
don't have money but they have [ __ ]
brains all right I think you think I
killed this subject I think I did I
think I drove that one in the [ __ ]
ground
oh yeah so anyway so this this is my
truce is mine this is my trip I can't
really discuss this so I'm going to
Bruins Maple Leafs then I do I dance
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] three shows in a
row and then I'm going to a Steelers
game and an Ottawa Senators game and
then I go to the [ __ ] Bruins
we're Winnipeg Jets game and that's it
that's my one my one fun trip that I do
every year that doesn't involve shows
and and that'll be it I'll have knocked
out all the [ __ ] Canadian teams other
than the Toronto Raptors I even went to
an Expos gave one time oh my life is
empty I told you that story I went up
there and I asked that [ __ ] douchebag
to take my picture and he act like he
didn't understand me that
french-speaking jackass I'm holding a
camera going can you do it I didn't
go [ __ ] yourself all right so let's get
to dilemmas this week everybody here we
go here's some dilemmas hey bill would
you rather have your grandmother's first
name or her haircut
yeah her haircut forever
fired her haircut forever I might as
well have her first name you know what I
take her first name I take a first name
all right
because I can always keep my mouth shut
walking into a bar no one has to know my
[ __ ] name I just have a first name
I'll just lie to people you know but if
I walk in with that haircut
that is it I'm gonna get a wrong kind of
attention I'm either gonna get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me or someone's gonna love
me in a way that I never wanted to be
loved so I'm taking the I take her first
name plus I think that's funny you know
I think you get some sympathy [ __ ] out
of that why do you have that Nate why is
your name Ethel uh yeah I don't know if
sir means my dad named me after my
grandmother you know I took a lot of
beat downs but you know I learned how to
UM anyways number two would you rather
have to use the same condom over and
over or use condoms covered with
pictures of Donald Trump Jesus Christ
that's a no-brainer
I'd use condoms with Charles Manson's
[ __ ] face on the end of it rather
than they'd use the same one over and
over was that like a dig on Donald Trump
I where I'd wear condoms with Donald
Trump's face on it even if they glow if
they glowed in the dark it's to wear and
you pulled a little string in it and it
was his voice going this is the greatest
condom ever number three would you
rather be publicly criticized for an
hour or publicly praised for an hour all
right that depends on what kind of
criticism it is if I could stand onstage
for an hour in front of people who are
going to get
about what I said about religion or what
I said about Black Friday I would do
that in a second that's gonna be way
more fun than sitting there getting
praised for an hour right and the way
you sit in that chair is incredible I
mean what do you say you have to [ __ ]
four minutes maybe that would be funny
to just sit there and watch somebody
have to praise me for an hour you know
what if I could get Joe DeRosa if Joe
DeRosa had to praise me for an hour I
would choose that and he had to be
sincere and he couldn't repeat anything
and he couldn't take you know other than
breathing normally he really couldn't
take a break and for a straight hour he
had to tell me why he thought I was
awesome I'd do that but other than that
I would take the criticism for an hour
number four
would you rather never wipe your ass for
the rest of your life or never put on
deodorant that's a no-brainer
no deodorant I'm not suffering your
armpits don't get itchy when they stink
[Laughter]
no I would just I would just have a
washcloth with me you know and I would
always wear I would always wear short
sleeves that were really loose and I
would just sort of every once in a while
a little dab'll do me right dude it
[ __ ] never wipe your ass for the rest
of your life I'd have to live near a
lake Billy going swimming again he swims
really weird why does he walk in till
the three feet of water crouch down and
just start vigorously rough gyrating in
the water with his arms up what is he
doing is he pelvic pumping
why is his legs so far apart that's got
to be bad on the hips that's what I
would do if I could never wipe my ass to
the rest of my life I would I would have
to live near a raging river and I would
stand with my [ __ ] ass pointed
upstream
[Music]
hanging onto some sort of [ __ ] log oh
Jesus
as opposed to no deodorant I choose that
I choose I just would I'd never wear
deodorant again I just moved to
Mississippi and nobody would notice all
right meet so yeah we're soul being a
trouble with the law
all right advice though my dad's 46
years old and swimming in the Bermuda
Triangle of midlife crisis oh Jesus
he started themselves for six months and
spent hours in the gym not accomplishing
much in the way of building muscle but
calls himself a beast I love this guy
add on every conversation leading to his
workouts him posting on Facebook like a
13 year old girl and him thinking he
should be a personal trainer soon and
this guy is a full-on douche how do I
tell them that he's just skinny with a
stick with his still ballooned head and
no 25 year old wants to bang him without
being a dick how do you tell him that
go [ __ ] yourself thanks for the advice
Jesus you know what dude I don't think
you'd get in the way of that one I I get
it you you're it you're embarrassed your
dad is embarrassing you all right so
what you have to do is you just have to
get past your embarrassment of your dad
you know at some point as you get older
you just have to accept that your
parents are who they are they're gonna
do what they're gonna do and you just
got to let go and you got to bring your
[ __ ] chick over whoever you have
friends over and don't try to control
the situation just let them be the
[ __ ] crazy people that they are all
right and there's two things that you
maybe make it better one you're [ __ ]
crazy two and number two they're not
half as crazy as you think they are
you just live with them and you are
[ __ ] hypersensitive to everything
that they do the way they coughed the
way they sneeze okay you know what I
mean it's like your friends are coming
over hearing that [ __ ] for the first
time so that they're not even gonna
notice I wrote recently I was hanging
out with a buddy of mine he's in his
thirties I'm in my 40s all right
his dad's over there his mom's
downstairs and his dad says to him hey
where do they where do they keep the
blah blah blah blah blah just a normal
question then my buddy goes dad why
don't you just go downstairs and ask her
instead of walking around just always
asking these questions and I remember
thinking like wow this guy does that all
the time and this annoys the [ __ ] out of
my buddy and I didn't even notice it all
right and I know table viously this guy
going to the gym and all that type of
[ __ ] he's just gonna look like a skinny
guy all right and if your dad really is
a weirdo and he's a [ __ ] spaz and all
that the person you with is gonna notice
it but if you're cool I think you come
off looking fine if you don't say
anything you just don't say anything you
know or you can just give the speech
before you go up if you bring in friends
and just be like yeah you know my dad's
a little nuts I wouldn't even do that
just let people figure it out you know
he's 46 years old dude and this you got
to give him you got to cut him some
slack
you're not 46 years old all right
someday you're gonna be right on that
cusp the final like I am the final
porthole of anybody from the opposite
sex remotely giving a [ __ ] about you you
know and you do that it's like this one
time I saw this snake choke this goat to
death and the goat was like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and at
the last second it just kicked its
[ __ ] legs like a maniac before it
just died that's what your dad's doing
I'm not saying he's gonna die but his
[ __ ] is [ __ ] career that's what he's
right at that point where he's just
flailing and kicking his legs and in the
end it's gonna happen he's gonna go to
the gym something's gonna
snap and then he'll just do some yoga or
something I don't know there's no way to
do it what were you gonna do that to
this guy okay this is the one thing he
has in his head it's telling that he
looks good just just let him [ __ ] do
it let him die his hair and just look
like a total jackass and one day he'll
notice and if he doesn't there's nothing
you can [ __ ] do about it but you
going over there and saying it it's just
gonna cause resentment and a big [ __ ]
argument just try to find the [ __ ]
humor in it in that total embarrassment
of a father you have alright now okay
overrated underrated for this week
overrated black nail polish
thanks Kardashians I'm sure this one
came from your [ __ ] gargling clothing
line way to step it up girls the auto
mechanic goth vampire dead body look is
lovely and sanitary
I haven't even know that's how out of
the [ __ ] loop I am I didn't is that
what women are wearing now
underrated free podcasts oh well isn't
that nice thank you underrated uh
quality over quantity I haven't been
laid in a while but it's not because I
don't want to okay I'm not even reading
the rest of this no wait I've been
laying a while it's not good okay no
you're right you're right I've somehow
was reading that was like you know I've
got laid in a while but it's been my
choice I'm waiting for something good to
come along I thought that you were
saying that I guess you're not alright I
haven't been laid in a while but it's
not because I don't want to it's because
I don't want the first chick oh he is
saying that because I don't want the
first chick back to be anything less
than a nine most of these broads inspire
me to hit the drive-through rip a bowl
and get a good night's sleep come on now
what do you [ __ ] Brad Pitt I got no
problem with you shooting for the stars
here alright you know if you don't want
to [ __ ] with anything less than a nine
I'm gonna tell you right now you're
gonna have a tremendous usual suspect
lineup of [ __ ] that you've gotten in
your life and you know what else you're
gonna have for the most part you can
have a bunch of stuck-up [ __ ] you know
why don't you settle into a seven or an
eight see how that treats you telling
you like the Nissan Maxima of [ __ ] you
know it's fast it can handle but also
you know it's a four-door sedan it's
very practical you're sitting there
going for that [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] to
see right you know you gotta take it
down have the carburetor adjusted they
even have carburetors anymore I don't
[ __ ] know I'm serious you know the
whole thing is just sitting there
quality over quantity you're looking at
women just physically at this point
which is you're probably yeah you know
what you're in the prime of your life
I'm coming at you like some old man
whose days are long past you know you
should get yourself a nice girl don't
listen to me you're absolutely right but
you know hitting the drive-through
becoming a fat [ __ ] and then smoking
weed I don't think that's gonna get you
a nine good night's sleep is good
moisturise underrated reunions all the
chicks get fat the dudes get the Baldwin
domes except me and my friends we win
they lose peaking in high school is for
[ __ ] not gay people but [ __ ] go to your
reunion get shit-faced and let people
know what you're made of you know I'd
never been to a high school reunion I
never been to one I first of all I was
out of the [ __ ] mailing loop you know
I think the senior class president was
supposed to be the one who organized
that and we we for some reason elected
somebody who wasn't gonna get that job
done so I've never gotten a [ __ ]
email until the last one my 20 year one
I got in in I knew of because between 15
and 20 became the whole social medias
and then what the hell was I doing I was
doing my uninformed radio show so plus
you know something I get enough people
that I went to high school with showing
up at my shows right isn't that the same
[ __ ] thing I don't know
IIIi don't I do something I would never
go to a high school reunion I think I'd
ever go to one of those they would just
make me feel like a [ __ ] loser I
don't know why I I do that like when I
go to my hometown and I Drive by my
[ __ ] high school I it just always
makes me feel like a [ __ ] loser I
look at it I don't know what it is I
don't like going back I like moving
forward um Jesus Christ am i all out of
material for this week and I got 9
minutes left what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
all right you want to hear my picks for
this week by the way I [ __ ] pick
Kansas City one week too early what they
did against Pittsburgh last night was
what I thought they were gonna do
against the Patriots I digged when I
should have zagged so this week I took
Pittsburgh given 10 and a half and then
I got [ __ ] so I guess they played
better at home who the [ __ ] knows this
is why I had this week I had the Green
Bay Packers one that one had the
Carolina Panthers one that one had the
Chicago Bears getting three lost that by
two I had the Pats and then I had the
Pittsburgh Steelers so we picked five
games this week I went three and two
birds he's got the Giants tonight
getting nine I like that I think that's
a great pick but you know after what I
said last week why would you listening
but I just think that's a great pick
because the Giants just perennial II
have a great [ __ ] defense and they
always have a good front for and if you
got a good front for and they can get in
the face of the [ __ ] quarterback you
know as we all saw when the Giants
[ __ ] ruin the Patriots perfect season
which still stings oh that still bugs me
when I think of that they can get in
Drew Brees for every nine points it's a
lot of [ __ ] points so I'm saying take
the Giants I'm gonna start picking the
Monday night games and what's gonna
happen is you guys gonna see a pattern
you're either gonna be like bill is
always right or [ __ ] what Bill saying
but either way you can use me as a
barometer do the exact opposite of what
he says or do the exact of what he says
oh you know what I bought this
but Black Sabbath's first first [ __ ]
album and I can't believe how long I
slept on these guys I was always always
like Black Sabbath but I was always like
a radio fan of Black Sabbath and I did
the Opie and Anthony program Tony Iommi
came in and he had a book and I'm
starting to read the book I'm getting
into their stuff and I'm listening to
all their music and I'm just like I'm
the biggest [ __ ] idiot it's like I
knew I was meeting a legend but I didn't
realize the level of legend that I was
it's probably better that I didn't I was
able actually able to [ __ ] ask a
couple of questions without sounding
like a dork in fact I asked him about
John bottoms foot technique you know
instead of asking him how to [ __ ] the
dead first album you made how did you
how was six five years earlier the
Beatles going she loves you yeah yeah
yeah and you within five years of that
you could come out with what you had
like [ __ ] unbelievable also YouTube
video this week man watch anything
that's I'm gonna have a link to one of
them Black Sabbath live in Paris 1970
and look at [ __ ] Bill Ward beating
the [ __ ] out of his goddamn drums and
you can already see I don't know you can
you can see the bottom just a little bit
of Bonham influence but what I love
about all of those guys all those rock
drummers from then was they all had a
jazz influence from when they were
growing up they all seemed you know cuz
when they they were born in like the 40s
so that was the end of the big band into
bebop then rock-and-roll and that had
that rockabilly swing anyways that's why
those [ __ ] drummers are so good I
think they got that swing pulse oh my
god could this [ __ ] be any more
[ __ ] obscure alright let's bring this
around here people I got three big shows
this weekend and I need some
[ __ ] to come out to these these
goddamn shows all right as I mentioned
and Doug Sinha is gonna be open enough
for me Doug Sid yeah
[ __ ] Boston kid is gonna be opening
for me I have not been was unless
someone's in Western Mass every time I
go to Western Massachusetts I think at
that time I played Lee Massachusetts
exit 2 off the mass Turnpike and that
[ __ ] [ __ ] threw that dinner roll
at me missed thank God through it like
[ __ ] 70 miles an hour
I hit the wall right the finally then he
ducked out of the room so you know
what's funny is oddly I always get a
little bit nervous when I go into
Western Massachusetts because that was
such a traumatic [ __ ] experience and
I'm not even on even joking if you've
never been on stage with lights in your
eyes and you can't [ __ ] see you know
beyond four [ __ ] rows so who's
kidding who for tables was a restaurant
hence the dinner roll and somebody does
something like that like the combination
of anger and fear I don't think that
ever goes away no matter how much yoga
you do I tell you guys I got back into
yoga I did like five hours of it last
week and I feel great I feel great but
what's funny is all I have is I have the
audio of one yoga class so it's the same
yoga class every time and I'm not gonna
mention the guy's name cuz I don't want
to blow up his spot but this guy's a
[ __ ] genius he's a [ __ ] genius
okay I've gone to his class it's
wall-to-wall people the hottest chick
she ever seen in your life and he walks
around getting them all stretched out
before he bangs him and as he does the
class he's suddenly throwing out this
[ __ ] about how he's good in bed
it's I actually hated it at first
because I was so [ __ ] jealous of the
genius of it and then I just had to let
go of that anger and be like you know
what this guy is the [ __ ] man he
figured it out god bless him hey there's
a line I got queue it up next week I
should have [ __ ] no I can't because
then I'll out the guy I don't want out
cuz he's got he's got an airtight just
Pied Piper a [ __ ] thing he has going on
over there I don't wanna [ __ ] ruin it
but at one point one of the lines he
goes he was describing the stretcher
doing and that it was basically like
somehow he sort of equated it to sex and
he's just going you know I mean think
about it
we're hot we're wet we're touching
ourselves everywhere I swear to god he
says that in the class laughs and then
he's got to get him back he goes
seriously seriously and he quickly he
gets it back on the rails like realizing
he took it too far and then he so every
day when I do this class the tape of the
class when he says that I always laugh
and then as he's going seriously I just
start going get him back get him back
you loosen up and he gets some right
[ __ ] back and I'm telling you I know
a lot of you right now a role in your
[ __ ] eyes but I was I've been there
it works not on all the Broads but if
they're all tens who gives a [ __ ] um oh
my god what is some of the other whoa oh
then he does that awful speaking for you
like I don't know what happened to him
at a gym I don't know if he ever got
beat up at like a Gold's Gym or
something like that but at one point he
goes um cuz he was actually doing this
one stress he goes this is good for your
kidneys or something like that he goes
people when you go to the gym let me ask
you a question uh what machine there is
for your kidneys
what machine is for your knees what
machine is for your spinal cord and how
many machines do they have for your by
sets in in and one whatever your
shoulders how has it go and then he goes
only heard this is cilia times is that a
health club honest aesthetics club and
he goes you know what the sad part is is
that we bought into it I don't know it's
funny to me just one of the things I
hate them
as an audience member even in a yoga
class is don't [ __ ] speak for me okay
I realize that nothing down there is
from my [ __ ] spinal cord but when
you're a young guy if you got [ __ ]
you got some biceps in a chest you're
gonna get laid you [ __ ] that's why I
went down there we're not it's not a
health club it's a getting [ __ ] club
and you're down here stretching out all
these [ __ ] before you [ __ ] them see
that even in yoga I get angry it's like
when I was watching [ __ ] Oprah last
night Oprah sitting around talking about
anger you know and was talking about
that Stella got her groove back chick
how Stella got her groove back right and
I know right now why were you watching
Oprah because we have one television all
right and when I watch hockey Nia is not
in there and when she's watching her
[ __ ] rather than extending the same
courtesy I sit there and trash the shows
that she's watching that's how I do it
bill why do you always only have one TV
cuz I live within my means which is why
I don't go down to Black Friday and get
trampled by some [ __ ] big gulp tub of
[ __ ] with a can of mace all right those
people who got mace they that lady did
them a favor do you think any of those
[ __ ] are gonna come back next Friday or
next Black Friday you think they're
gonna come down there for that [ __ ]
they're not they got the beat down they
deserved just like that [ __ ] douche
yeah that's inviting did [ __ ]
Thanksgiving he's got nowhere to go good
let him stay home for a Thanksgiving
maybe he'll do some work on himself and
wonder why he's alone
Oh evidently people think I'm a douche
but what happens is is you keeps getting
invited every [ __ ] year because
people feel bad for him and now he gets
this false sense itself of like well I'm
amazing not only do I always have a
place to go for Thanksgiving
it's always a whole new group of people
it's an endless list of people that want
to eat with me he doesn't realize that
he's getting passed around cuz he's a
douche
all right she got lightheaded screaming
like that um so anyways the mmm podcast
bill at the mmm podcast calm that's the
podcast for this week everybody a little
touch-and-go this week little in and out
you know if I were to equate this this
podcast I would say would be like you
know when though the f16 tries to refuel
in flight
it comes up Oh missed it came up missed
it i but connected yeah we lost it
that's how I felt this one was anyways
we go to bill bird comm we have a new
merch page we have Monday morning
podcast t-shirts if you go to the mm
podcast comm if you want to make a
donation you can and uh and if you don't
want to I don't give a [ __ ] I'm still
gonna do these there's no pressure
there's no pressure there's no guilt you
tight [ __ ] um that's it that's a
podcaster this week I'll talk to you
guys next week I will be in Pittsburgh
going to this steel is game and of
course I had to unplug it one more time
but in the podcast that's it that's it
for this week go [ __ ] yourselves don't
take any [ __ ] and stop going to these
stupid [ __ ] events alright [ __ ] Black
Friday [ __ ] the iPhone until it's in the
store
[ __ ] Saint Patrick's Day [ __ ]
Valentine's Day [ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] those [ __ ] who shoot
the t-shirts at yet the game go [ __ ]
yourself you can go down to you go down
a Foot Locker buy like 20 of them
alright that's it see ya
you